hello my name's Forrest Forrest Gump
would you like a chocolate oh thank you
it's funny what a young man rep collects
you're the same as everybody else you
are no different young boys different
promises to be exist if it does and
Jenny I'm throws for school she was my
most special friend my only friend we
put together all the time we were like
peas and carrots
you wouldn't believe it if I told you
but I could run like the wind blows who
in the hell is that
that is false golf coach that's the
local idiot I never thought it would
tighten me anywhere
baby put me on a thing called the
all-america team
well you get to make the President of
the United States
gratulations have to feel be an
all-american now maybe it's just me but
college was very confusing times if you
have been with a girl florist sit next
to them in the home economics class all
the time
have you given any thought to your
future Vietnam and you promise me
something okay
if you ever in trouble don't try to be
brave you just run okay okay where you
boys run in the world Alabama it wins no
we are not relationship some reason when
I was doing seem to make sense to people
ordered the Medal of Honor
oh come now my mama's always telling me
how miracles happen every day
some people don't think so do you come
home with me my house and Greenbow I'll
take care of you why are you so good to
me you're my girl Paramount Pictures
presents Tom makes a nice smart man but
I know what love is Robin right will you
marry me I'd make a good husband Ginny
you would Forrest you won't marry me
Gary Sinise I never thanked you for
saving my life and Sally feel my forest
is gonna get the same opportunities as
everyone else
a film by Robert Zemeckis what's Martha
cinema
you're gonna have to figure that out for
you say
the world will never seem the same once
you've seen it through the eyes of
Forrest Gump my mom always said life was
like a box of chocolates you never know
what you're gonna get
you